okay so we already talked a little bit
about
the unrest that we saw over the weekend
in different cities across the country
clashes everything from pepper spray
trump trucks with flags driving into
people i mean we just saw all sorts of
different stuff and the point i tried to
make
was that arguing about what percentage
of the unrest and violence is coming
from
from either side from each side is not
really an effective use of time and that
even though it's counterintuitive
i believe that chaos and unrest helps
donald trump
uh secure re-election if it does
anything at all
well outgoing trump adviser kellyanne
conway
was recently interviewed and she said
that from her perspective the more chaos
there is
she used the words anarchy and vandalism
the better it is and in terms of
the choice between trump and biden on
public safety and law and order now i
happen to agree with her
i think she's completely wrong on the
facts in other words
trump's president now and the chaos he's
pointing to is happening now
that doesn't really justify reelecting
trump so i disagree with her that it
actually illuminates who would be better
on this issue
vice president joe biden was vice
president for eight years we didn't have
this type of chaos then but from a
political standpoint
and in terms of who supports which
candidate i believe she is right let's
take a look at what she had to say
also notice there was a quote today from
a restaurateur in wisconsin saying
are you protesters trying to get donald
trump reelected he knows
full stop and i guess mayor pete knows
full stop that the more
chaos and anarchy and vandalism and
violence reigns
the better it is for the very clear
choice on who's best on public safety
and law and order one of the i was in
fort mchenry last
a logical person would say wait wait a
second
trump is president and it's chaotic you
don't expect that same president to fix
the issue you change
president if you want the issue fixed
reelecting the guy
during whom during whose presidency
there's chaos isn't going to stop
the chaos the reality is that they
are creating these images of chaos
with footage from portland it's being
strategically disseminated
you know look at some of the usual
suspects some of the so-called
enlightened centrists on the internet
who claim to be unbiased arbiters but
who are furthering this exact
narrative that things would be far less
chaotic if trump gets re-elected
they use this to rile up their base
trump has been doing it
for a while we saw it during the rnc
using the phrase
violent anarchists or anarchists as
trump often says mispronouncing it
marxists they talk about uh socialist
communists etc
who are out there and they want to hurt
the police and they want to hurt people
and all of this different stuff
this is called chaos pr chaos public
relations
and it is counter-intuitive i get that
it's counter-intuitive and i understand
why some in the audience don't agree
with me
vladimir putin has used this stuff um
benjamin netanyahu in israel previously
previously used
more what we would call fear public
relations
than chaos public public relations but
it's certainly
related and the idea is that
when you're let me let me see how i can
explain this
in the clearest way when your um
uh pop when your uh uh constituents
are the ones more likely to be activated
by chaos
the fact that the chaos is happening
under your watch doesn't hurt you
and if there are a whole bunch of people
remember half the country doesn't vote
but there are a bunch of people in the
non-voters who would support biden if
they voted
and there's a whole bunch of people in
the non-voters who would support trump
if they voted if you can find an issue
that disproportionately activates your
side
it really doesn't matter if it's idiotic
to suggest
that hey it's chaotic under my watch
re-elect me and i'll stop the chaos
the lack of of logic in that actually
doesn't matter
the biden campaign is increasingly
understanding this trump step
uh biden's deputy campaign manager kate
bettingfield said over the weekend
trump is deliberately inciting violence
and i believe he is because he believes
it will benefit him
the united states globally has become a
joke under this presidency
and donald trump is doing something that
should be laughed out of office which is
trying to get reelected by gaslighting
people
about the current state of affairs trump
had a failed coronavirus response
it caused chaos it costs medical chaos
cultural chaos economic chaos
trump then blames the chaos on the left
and says re-elect me and i'll fix this
wait a second you caused it trump is
essentially trying to be both the
arsonist and the fireman
right create the crisis and present
himself as the hero who can fix it and
to that end
he is manipulating the bases of both
parties
and getting the bases of both parties to
play active roles
understand the i don't want to call it
genius because i don't know that it's
calculated
but what donald trump is doing by
inciting violence and unrest
is he's activating the so-called law and
order people on his side
to get out and vote and he's also
activating
the people on the left who are furious
about what's going on
to go and protest and while most of the
protesters are overwhelmingly peaceful
it is going to foment the narrative
that he wants of an angry out of control
uh anarchist left which is not accurate
but
it is doing things to both bases that i
believe benefits him now unfortunately
fact-checking this won't help
we've been fact-checking it for a long
time it's beyond fact checking
and to i i'm assuming i don't have to
say this to you
when the incumbent president believes
that generating more chaos in the
streets retweeting videos of
street fights as trump did over the
weekend which i will tell you about
uh it is not a good situation when that
is what the incumbent president believes
will get him reelected
it's even worse when he might be right
and of course this strategy
disproportionately works on people who
can easily be bamboozled there are a lot
of those people
in trump's constituency so the question
is what should we do
i don't have an answer for you today i'm
going to think about it
and hopefully follow up with you later
this week if you have thoughts i do want
to hear from you you can let me know
via twitter deepakman one of our
sponsors today
is hydrant and they are giving my
audience 25
off your first order this has been a
game changer for me this is a refreshing
electrolyte powder that you mix directly
into your water
to rehydrate your body because it is
packed
with the four essential electrolytes
that your body needs the most
that's sodium potassium magnesium and
zinc
and because of how hydrant is formulated
it's an efficient way of getting
yourself rehydrated
and it tastes awesome there's a variety
of flavors
i have blood orange which i love you can
also get grapefruit
and lime a lot of us don't even realize
when we're dehydrated a lot of the time
and it's become a really great part of
my daily routine
if i'm under hydrated i'm affected
physically
i'm affected mentally and i think
you never fully understand this until
you use hydrant for the first time
i get a great a a boost of energy when
i'm properly hydrated if i've been
dehydrated
they also have a version with caffeine
which i love
if and when that's what i'm looking for
everyone in my audience gets 25 percent
off your first order
when you go to drinkhydrant.com
pacman or just enter the code pacman at
checkout
i've put the link right underneath this
video